hello everyone tonight while I was
sleeping my channel hit 50,000
subscribers but we'll get back to that
as that is not the greatest news I have
for you today the greatest news I have
for you comes from Chennai or in this
case from Italy as that is where Ramesh
Babu Prag nonde is playing the World
Junior Championship and this is a game
from round 8 he plays against a wonderly
Inc and the one ruling is one of the one
of America's greatest prodigies he is
the I think tenth or eleventh youngest
Grandmaster ever in history and his
second youngest Grand Master in America
I think behind Samuel 7 and quite an
amazing player and he he meets a
pregnant unda in round 8 so one run
before the tournament ends and pregnan
de again creates an amazing game and if
Bravo continues doing this I'm gonna
have to open up another channel and just
to show progress games so so let's see
this game like I said is this is round 8
and Prabhu has the white pieces we have
e4 e5 Knight to f3 knight c6 Bishop to
c4 detail in game Bishop to c5 and in
this position
Drago played before the Evans gambit I'm
of course kidding no he didn't he went
for c3 the main line we have Knight to
f6 D 3 d6 and Bishop to b3 he plays
Bishop to b3 he doesn't want to allow
Knights to a Knight to a5 to force white
to give up the light square bishop so
when the bishop is on b3 he can retreat
the c2 if needed
Alliant castles and Bishop to g5 and you
know pinning the knight a nice square
for the bishop developing Bishop to e6
by Lee and and nice to d2 and this is an
interesting position black does have
quite a lot of options here he can he
can maybe play h6 or maybe maybe decided
that he 6 isn't the best square for this
Bishop maybe retreat it to B to d7
but as he already played Bishop to e6
you know it's not it's not that in
resting or easy for a person to admit
that you know some square you just
developed your piece to isn't the best
square for it and he captures on b3 and
this isn't something you'd expect from
such a strong player he's rated
somewhere around twenty five sixty
capturing with the a pond here does seem
like the way to go you know you're
getting the opening a file you do mess
up your structure a bit but you are
capturing towards the center so this is
always good for why but why not to
develop the Queen for free so pin
capture some b3 this comes with a tempo
you're attacking b7 and the link has to
find a good answer to this he plays
Bishop to b6 and here probably again he
has a quite a lot of options he can
decide to go for a four he can decide
the castle but he plays the most
annoying move for black he plays Knight
to c4 and now black has to deal with the
fact will white capture the bishop why
did I allow white to capture my bishop
and in this interesting position leaning
kind of plays an inaccuracy he doesn't
really play the best movie plays Queen
to e7 and this allows Prague to really
go go for some interesting ideas a more
precise mood be something like rook to
b8 because now if a force played black
has this option of playing Knight to a5
attacking the Queen and the night and
after white captures Bishop captures now
the rook is protecting the b7 pawn and
always well for black black will at some
point push c6 he will free the c7 square
for the bishop Oh as well and he does
get to keep the bishop but after Knight
to c4
liyan played the Queen to e7 and here
perago really doesn't give Liang a
moment to breed he plays a four of
course now threatening a 5 we have 9th
to d8 now the knight will be protecting
the b7 pawn and interestingly Prague
does not push a 5 here a 5 is a very
interesting idea and it creates a very
complicated game but instead Prague
castles if fragra decided to
push a five this would be this might not
be the best way to go because after a
five link does have Bishop to c5 and
here there is this d4 move after he
captures C captures it does seem like
the bishop is trapped and in fact it is
but black does get some counter play
after Queen 24 Czech Bishop to e3 and
now Bishop captures on d4 Knight
captures an D for winning the bishop but
now Queen captures on g2 and after white
castles Queen side for example okay
why did win a piece but he's down three
pawns so it's not it probably is winning
for for let's say a computer but against
a human there will be a lot of counter
play for black here so instead of going
good into all these complications I mean
he does have the white pieces why allow
it
after Knight to d8 Prague Castle and now
Prague way is definitely threatening a5
since after a 5 and d4 Queen captures on
e4 does not come with check anymore
we have h6 and Bishop to h4 here we have
c6 and now comes Knight capture some b
6h captures a capture some b6 and this
pawn on d6 is hanging and capturing the
pawn isn't the best move Prager plays
Bishop captures on f6 because this pawn
isn't going anywhere you can always
capture it but if you capture it
immediately then black does get some
counter counter play for the point after
g5 Bishop g3 and for example Knight the
e6 this night is coming to f4 this night
is coming to h5 to threaten the bishop
you know black would have a decent
counter play here so after a capture
some b6 Pro go first captures the night
before capture screen captures and only
now he captures on b6 so clean captures
on b6 and Prague 1 upon this is move 16
and he want a pawn against the 20 560
player and there is an old thing by
William Stein it's he said give me a
pawn and I will win the game so which
time is always said that if you're a
pawn up you
must win the game you know if there
isn't any real positional imbalance in
the game so progress seems to like this
idea shine it said and he really he
really goes all out to win this game
Knights the e6 we have Queen back to III
rook to a6 Leah now is preparing to
double up on the a file - maybe maybe
get some counter play for the pawn rook
to a3 Prague also prepares the double up
on the a file rook f28 and rook F to a
One Nights the c5 now we have b3 and
Queen to e6 now with a double attack on
the b3 pawn Knight to d2 defending the
pawn Knight goes to d7 and we have b4
now preparing to expand on the Queen on
the Queen side b6 and out d4 d5 he
captures on d5 Queen captures on d5
Knight to f3 now with a threat of
capturing the pawn on e5 and here link
captures it captures on d4 not capturing
this pawn with ideas like maybe efore or
protecting it with f6 would result in in
Prague having this beautiful pawn chain
on the Queen side and against these two
pawns the black has it would be very
easy so instead he captures on d4 we
have Queen captures on d4 progress very
confident in his ability to win the game
being a pawn up so he offers the
exchange of Queens Liam of course
accepts we have captured capture and
Knight to e5 and this it seems like this
is a really good opportunity as the
knight is attacking the c6 pawn this
Knight is defending the c6 pawn so it
might seem like f4 is the way to go you
know we kick away tonight so why not
kick it away and grab the pawn black
again does get some counter play if a
brute move like this was played after
Knight to c4 this comes with a tempo on
the look on a3 look a 2 and now after c5
black would get some contemplative for
the pawn so instead Prague doesn't allow
this after 95 he first plays rook 3 to 8
to not allowing Knight c4 which tempo so
like immediately goes for c5 Knight to
f5
we have seek after some before see
capture some before and now Knight to d3
we have Knight to e7 check King goes to
h7 and Knight to d5 now protecting his
own pawn and attacking the b6 pawn and
well the threat is of course b5 I'm
kicking away the rook and winning the b6
pawn and there really isn't anything
lien can do about this rook 6 to a7 was
played given up the given up the pawn
but first rook to a3
now with the attack on the knight Knight
goes three five and night characters on
b6 now progress two pawns up and this is
completely winning for white rook to d8
was played a five now pushing the pawns
pants past bonds must be pushed Knight
to c6 attacking the b4 pawn rook to b3
defending roopd for adding more pressure
to the before pawn but rook to be one
again defends the pawn rook to e7
and now as progress have to pass pawns
on the Queen side the this a5 and B for
pawn are beautiful liyan will try to get
some counter play as he does have the
two rooks so maybe maybe he can place
them on the second rank and get some
sort of a perpetual check h3 prabhu you
know best to be safe not allow any back
rank ideas rook to e2 now preparing to
double up on the second rank you know -
I'd add F to pawn a six Prague continues
to push his F pawn he's passed pawn rook
d2 d2 and now eyeing that f2 point and
Knight to c4 would attempt on the route
can be won so rook to a-1 now the threat
is the capture DF to pawn and also to
capture the a 6-point but b5 stops all
these threats now this comes over the
tempo on the night and unfortunately
lien cannot give up this night for some
sort of a perpetual which rook captures
an F - if this was played rook captures
an F - then he probably can simply
capture the night because black does not
have a perpetual after rook
after skiing f1 rook F - kinky one
rookie - king b1 and now there is no
more chicks as the knight is protecting
d2 so after something like rook to H -
okay he can threaten a checkmate with
roof - h1 but Rock simply blocks the
rockin a2 and after something like check
King's if you check King b3 now lien
would be forced to exchange rooks and
after capture capture and capture Roxy
won this is completely winning for white
after a couple of more moves this pawn
is up there and the night will simply
become the roof so instead of all this
after b5 Ali and saw that he can't
really give up the night he played
Knights the d4 rook to a3 was played now
offering the exchange of rooks rook
captures an f2 now at least grabbing
upon while exchanging works rook
captures rook captures and we have b6
rook captures on a6
and this is this could have been a
critical moment in the game because of
course the b-pawn cannot be stopped
everyone everyone sees that but it's
better for it to be you know winning
then almost winning here Prague could
have played something like Knight to e5
and there is definitely no stopping this
point whatever in whatever way because
now the Black Knight can come to c6 to
protect b8 so after something like if
black tried something like f6 to kick
the night away now b7 and this is
completely winning but unfortunately in
this position Prague didn't go for 95 he
played b7 and of course the knight
cannot be stopped but black does get
some counter play if he played 95 the
game is instantly over but ok knight c6
and progress sides to win a piece so b8
with Queen Knight captures rook captures
and he does have a knight for a pawn but
still there will take a couple of moves
to finish this rook to a7 now rub the b6
Prabhu has to improve the position of
this night to somehow threaten f7 and
grab upon and then he will be winning
rook to e7 king f - g 6r up to d6 King
g7 Knight b6 rook a7 can get three
improving the position of the king
rook b8 Knight d5 rugby 793 rook a7 lien
doesn't want to allow the rook progress
rook to come to the seventh ranked night
c4 rook to e7 r up to d5 now can get six
rook c5 King back to G 795 King f6 some
was repeating moves king get for now
even more improving the position of the
king rock a7 rook checks King goes back
and rook see for not allowing Roque for
check rook a to now g4 I hope to have to
check Knight f3 rook a to h4 rook a 1
rugby for RuPt the c1 rook to d4 rook
the a1 rope to d7 rook a for check
Knight d4 rook to a 1 now rook the b7
erupted f1 Knight to f3 rook to f2 now
rub the d7 into g8 King to e3 rook to f1
Knight to e5 and this is definitely the
critical moment in the game as he rally
and missed probably lien here missed a
chance to draw the game in this position
lien played rock to H 1 what he should
have played was rook to e1 with Czech
probably both players were already in
time trouble you know it's you don't
have a night for a pawn but still it's
not that easy to win this if black plays
correctly but after roof do you want
check and after something like King to
f4
you have g5 check and after H captures H
captures now if you capture the pawn you
lose the knight on d5 for example
captures f6
sorry you lose the night and if I would
rook captures and
this is very very unfortunate and even
if you don't capture if you play
something like f5 rooked f1 check again
if you go back then rook e1 again if you
capture now f6 is a threat
checking the king and this is this is a
draw unfortunately and if rook to e1
check you don't you don't go King f4 for
example if you play King to d4 then you
get f6 and after something like rook
checks King g7 night here after up to g1
the rook will gobble up these pawns and
with three connected pawns black has it
will be it will be extremely hard if
even possible to win this with white so
after 95
liyan missed rocky one and he played
rook to h1 so because of promised that
ninety five move to win the game
immediately he'll out a strong
grandmaster like a wonderly and to get
away maybe with a draw but fortunately
for Prague liyan missed it he played
rook to h1 and now it's definitely
winning for Prague he played Knight
captures on f7 rook captures an age for
Knight to e5 now protecting the pawn g
g5 King to e4 now h5 and he did manage
to get rid of all of White's pawns but
King at 5h capture son g5 and now King
g6 and there are no more chances for
black here whatever black plays with
what best defense and with some silly
moves it's checkmate in 6 moves
he tried King f8 not allowing or up to
d8 checkmate but after knight c6 i
Wanderley and resigned to the game and
this has moved 79 even though Prager
could have won the game like 30 30 moves
ago or maybe even 35 I don't I don't
know which move was that Knight to e5
again but now the Knight is guarding
East 7 King be 8 isn't really helping
since rock to d8 is checkmate the night
is now covering his 7 King is covering
f7 and there is no move link can play in
this position
so a wonderful game and a wonderful idea
how Prabhu got it all in there you know
that night the sea for threatening the
bishop on v6 and the lien just played
that small in accuracy Queen to e7 and
Prague was immediately all over the
board
so yeah Prague Oh finally won his first
Grand Master norm and well regardless of
the norms I think you have to have like
over 2600 rating performance to get a GM
norm progress performance in this
tournament is somewhere around 20 740 so
quite crazy he's after round 8 he has
six and a half points out of eight so
quite an amazing result and yeah if he
wins the next game he's playing against
the Atari Grandmaster Qatar is something
I can't remember the surname a
grandmaster from Norway irate at twenty
five hundred and eighty and if he wins
that game he becomes the youngest Grand
Master in chess history and not only
that the youngest world junior champion
in chess history but you know as usual
no pressure
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I definitely did I would like
to thank Hector Betancourt dance sealer
Stephan Hines John Fogerty and Diego
Cascone Castro for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and I said I
will get back to my channel hearing
50,000 subscribers yes that did happen
and I'm very very happy about it you
know thank you everyone for supporting
me for creating such a beautiful chess
community where you know people can well
on most days come and enjoy themselves
and I will do a stream on Friday and I
will prepare some reward you know a
giveaway but I will inform I will inform
you about it in a video aside from this
one so I don't spam this video with
information about this but just so you
know it will be on Friday and there will
be some
giveaway going on and some guests will
show up so yeah thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon